magnetic resonance imaging commonly
known as MRI helps doctors find watch
and treat medical problems MRI uses very
strong magnets radio waves and a
computer to make pictures of the inside
of the body MRI pictures are more
detailed than those made with other
methods there are many reasons to have
MRI MRI may find bleeding such as
bleeding in the brain
brain changes as in stroke
problems with your back such as a
herniated disc
and an injury inside the body such as a
torn anterior cruciate ligament
before MRI you will remove all metal
objects
and it's not safe to have MRI with some
medical implants you should tell the MRI
technologist about any metal device or
implant you may have in your body such
as a pacemaker to prepare for MRI you
will lie on a table just outside the
scanner MRI scanners are very noisy so
you will probably wear earplugs or
headphones
different equipment such as pillows and
straps will help you stay in the correct
position once you are ready the table
will slide into the scanner most often
closed scanners such as this one are
used
the area inside is very narrow in some
areas open scanners are available this
scanner is open on the sides so you
won't be completely surrounded by the
machine
however the pictures may not be as good
as with closed scanners for either type
of scanner a technologist will operate
it from the next room you will be able
to talk to each other through a two-way
speaker
during the scan magnets in the machine
will create a strong magnetic field this
will not harm you
then the scanner will send radio waves
through your body this will not harm you
when the radio waves are turned off the
scanner will pick up energy signals from
your body
these signals are used to make the
pictures during the scan you will have
to stay very still so the images will be
clear you may be asked to hold your
breath for a short time
MRIs may take 30 to 45 minutes or longer
to complete in some cases you may get
contrast dye with your MRI the dye helps
make clearer pictures
after the MRI you can resume your normal
activities if you received contrast dye
the technologist may ask you to drink
plenty of water or other healthy drinks
to help your kidneys remove the dye from
your body